[Music]
darby 11 days
honestly what are we doing here i told
myself the same thing rehab doesn't work
but excuse me
phone for you
my mom is in the hospital i have to
leave darvey you know the rules
you leave and you're back in jail
[Music]
the road's closed i have to get to salt
lake city no one's getting through until
the storm passes i opened up the visitor
center for some folks wait it out there
so what's your name darby sandy hey i'm
ash
ours do you have the wi-fi
no there's no wi-fi i got one bar by the
tree for about 10 seconds
[Music]
hey are you okay
make yourself comfortable
what what we are here till the storm
clears
getting you out of here as soon as i can
the trick is play the man not the hand
everybody's got a tail huh
what's yours
you're gonna have to figure that one out
for yourself
go
put your weapon down
i don't want to die here
i have to go now
oh it's gonna be a long night
[Music]
turn out the lights
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you